hey man here it is
so
we'll start with this yeah why not
I think this makes sense
so if you go and search this it's all
over the internet
uh quickest path to be high value man
where's rolla's original tweet I think
this is it over here
well let's deal with a few of these
because people you know did their own
takes of it right uh
whatever their ego investment happened
to be in see so the thing is when you
ask somebody what a high value man is if
you ask 20 different people you get 20
different answers you ask 20 different
women you'll get 20 different answers if
you ask 20 different guys in their 20s
from 20 different guys in their 50s
you'll get very different answers from
both those groups
um
to Define it clearly and concisely I
don't remember where I saw it I think it
might have been Chateau heartiste or
something like that but it's it's
clearly you know become the man that
other men want to be and the one that
you know women want to be with sort of
thing
um and again the definition changes
and who you ask and how old they are
when you ask them but it's funny that
all of this got taken out of context
over what is
what appears to me anyway to be Rolo's
attempt to get some traction or some
eyeballs on this stuff
um
there it is it's probably the most
concise one we'll look at some of the
other versions of it in a second
uh the quickest path to becoming a
higher value man is one do not get
married avoid family creation vasectomy
in your 20s I think this is the one that
triggered the most people or got them to
get their attention on it see
I put out this uh tweet
um it's a few years ago four years ago
something like that and it was something
about said moms
um like seven steps or six steps or
whatever the hell it was I can't
remember what it was but the internet
took it and they ran with it and I was
on morning shows and news Medias and if
you like if you search for Rich Cooper
you'd see the tweet and articles written
about it by left hearts
so
this is you know similar sort of thing
it's a listicle listicles do well on
Twitter by the way if you're new to
social media especially if they contain
controversial uh things like hey if
you're a young man just get your ball
snipped right so number three is get a
vasectomy in your 20s lift consistently
eliminate all sedations learn game and
networking play to your strengths build
wealth resist easing up on your focus
and I think this is a reply to this
author Richard Reeves
um I read his book I didn't read his
book I listened to his book several
months ago didn't really say much about
it didn't think much of it it was okay
it's you know the standard observation
of the facts that have already been
stated but with some uh apologies and
you know but this is how women are
affected sort of thing
anyway so
this is a list of eight whatever you
know standard sort of stuff uh be raised
in the house of elrond you know whatever
nerds uh stingy Stingray what was one
that Ben Shapiro did
where's Ben Shapiro's
because he was brought up during this
fresh and thick clip
okay so Ben Shapiro's I'm not sure why
this was cut and pasted in here but he
says quickest paths become a high value
man so it looks like you just copied uh
Rolos stay healthy get a job get married
go to church synagogue have kids develop
a skill set and then deploy it in the
most Market driven way six points to I
think Rolo's eight
so be religious just get married get a
job stay healthy you know standard stuff
I look
this interpretation of value
is going to vary like I said earlier if
you ask a
30 year old chick
if a guy with a job a job which for the
most part means just over broke is high
value
I don't know if she's going to get too
excited about that
you know uh you got to bring more to the
table than just the job today that was
good with our grandfather parents era
you know you could have a job at the
toothpaste Factory screwing on the tops
of toothpaste tubes and that was just
fine you know having a job was
sufficient because you could have a
house you could have white picket fence
you'd have the car you'd have the
vacation every you know uh two three or
four weeks per year depending on where
you would live
being religious going to church having
kids yeah this was this would all be
typically defined as high value in my
grandparents era for sure
I don't know that
um it's Rolo's
avoiding family
uh I mean I'm not a fan of marriage
obviously I have a chapter in my book on
why smart men tend to avoid marriage
um so it's one that everybody's going to
debate
avoiding having children that's kind of
the point of being here scatter seed
right uh vasectomy in your 20s that's
that's where he goes just kind of like
full art hard right
um and that was the point of this tweet
was to get people's attention at work
because the internet talked about it he
daily wire talked about it Ben Shapiro
added him I'm sure he talked about it on
the show I don't watch their stuff uh
I'm sure Matt Walsh got on board and of
course you know it went around the
interwebs and then a blue hair cuckold
um got into an argument with uh Rolo so
I'll get to that video in a second we'll
deal with that now I think we're far
enough into the video that we can get to
the swearing because that's how it is
um let's Okay so
that's the motorcycle clip I wanted to
deal with
snico and Destiny ask Rolo tomasi what a
high value man is okay let's get that up
on the screen
present share
and
Zen it there it is
oh hang on I gotta get the audio in on
that
uh share audio tab yeah okay so you
should be able to hear this
so it's a two minute clip I don't know
how long the full thing went it seemed
to go on forever
um I did go back and watch the full
thing earlier today but um this is like
the version of the clip that I saw when
I was scrolling Twitter it's like Rollo
on the fresh fit arguing with a blue
haired cuck and a guy named snico I
don't know too much about snico from
what I understand he's a streamer or was
a streamer he got removed off a YouTube
or something like that
um
somebody in the chat can Google and tell
me what he's famous for maybe and you've
got uh this blue hair cuckold
um who I've known of him for a few
months now I've seen him before
um there was a point where I was working
with uh Suleiman Ahmed I think he was
doing some work on the research on why
the Tates were in jail and he he was
apparently going to come on to provide
an opposing point of view but he never
showed up or I don't know something
happened but um yeah he's he's making
the rounds I'm not really sure why at
this point
um and why he would chime in on a
conversation about what a high value man
is I mean
you guys tell me let's just play it
you can walk back from what is your
definition of a high value man it
doesn't matter that's not what I was
talking about in this matter I don't
know what you're talking about that's
what the front of the first part of the
Tweet is how to become a high value miss
the fastest way to become a high value
man is to recognize to recognize the
fact that you've got that you've got
sacrifices to make okay like stories
from Vietnam like just say what is a
high value man it's the first part of
The Suite what does that mean you tell
me what a high value man is because
here's the thing is it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter what I'm going to say is
a high value man as good as your [__]
tweet yeah
it doesn't matter what I say is a
[__] high value man because everybody
takes this the point of the [__]
tweet is that everybody is going to take
this and then insert their own
definition of what a [__] high value
man it is
12 kids when you're 16.
then your Tweet doesn't work does it
what if your definition of a high value
man is being uh getting into a trade and
having five kids by the time you're 22.
being an Esports professional you're
absolutely making my point for me right
here okay that's what I'm saying I'm
just gonna pause this for a sec because
you've got the Young
tldr generation on the left hand side of
the screen that wants to get to the
point and you've got Rolo on the other
side who will take seven hours on a
stream to get to the point they both get
to the point that they want to arrive at
it's just this is one of the problems
with this conversation I can see right
off the bat
s you gave a list of eight things do
these do the things becoming
do one through eight
years the fastest way to becoming a high
value man is these toys what is that so
here's the thing so if we're talking
about family creation okay so you want
to go okay let's go one by one you want
to go one by one okay
before one by one what is high value man
we can't have an argument if I don't
even know but the very fact that you're
even asking this in the first place is
the actual point of the [__] tweet
okay so if you if you're going to be a
high value man with the [__] hands
tie behind your back then what is that
what does that mean to you that's the
point this whole discussion is the point
of the [__] tweet you guys the Tweet
was you've got some conception of high
value man here are eight points that you
think you need to do to get to it and
now you're getting blown the [__] up on
the vasectomy thing which you probably
realize is [__] [__] but you're
too old and stubborn to walk back from
it that's the point of this government
it makes you stubborn and [__] walk
back from it because the point of it was
to get douche nozzles like yourself to
[__] have this conversation in the
first place how old are you bro douche
nozzles
all right douche nozzles that's the word
of the day
um man
so arguing on arguing on the internet
hang on let me go to
um
something else here to kind of frame
this for you like I
I just couldn't imagine this this is
just you know you turn on
turn on social media sometimes or
video shows and then you get fed this
stuff
um let's go stop screen let's put this
up here and share
and
this one here is one that I want to show
you so if you don't know who uh Destiny
is this is him on a stream with his
honorable wife or girlfriend or whatever
but
um he lets her bang other dudes and this
is another dude over here watch this
I'm not going to play the audio on this
one because it because it's got an audio
track so it'll uh
it'll be an issue for the YouTube but
anyway he's sitting there and it's you
know the camera just zooms on him you
know playing sad music and she's dancing
in the background this black dude doing
some I don't know a salsa dance or
whatever
the look on his face says it all but
this is who this is who's engaging in an
argument about what a high value man is
right like this is this is the state of
social media this is a state of all this
like why are you even debating the issue
with people like this
you know remove you guys can go see that
on my Twitter Twitter feed and hear the
audio uh to it but it is what it is it
is what it is uh what is a high Valley
man it's what it's a guy that other men
want to want to be around or to be or a
guy that women want to be with it's as
simple as that
um I saw during the longer form of the
content during the argument
um Rollo was uh I think he said Elon
Musk and Jeff Bezos aren't High Valley
men which is pretty stupid I mean
like I'm sure Elon Musk cares first of
all to begin with
um he's building Rockets spaceships and
cars and digging holes in tunnels under
people's company oh I'm running social
media platforms like Twitter apparently
too uh he's got 10 kids with something
like five or six different women I have
no idea what the count is now but it's
just like you know it gets to that point
where it's just absurdity that it's oh
he is or he isn't and I haven't you know
been kind to elon's relationship choices
in the past but he's certainly high
value man men want to be him and women
want to be with him as autistic and as
awkward as he is or wherever he is on
the Spectrum whatever it happens to be I
think he says he has Asperger's but
as as awkward as he can be and uh you
know the man that is what he does men
want to be him he has a massive
following on social media and women want
to be with him women still want his his
seat and he's happy to uh spread it he's
been doing it for quite a few years now
so there's that you guys you guys
chopped that up in the show but it's
like it's just weird watching these like
hour-long sessions over something that's
so
simple anyway I like to keep things
simple that's that's just my style I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out